we can say lots of things about
alex he's a long-time friend of the
conference i think you were even here
for the first one the first dcr gov one
uh and i can really feel you what's
going on in your life right now you've
really gone he's gotten into a lot of
home improvement projects
so last week he installed a new
electrical circuit board in
to in the bathroom it's a new electrical
circuit to the bathrooms you could get a
vent exhaust
which is a good project to do and the
fan is working great he says
but there's also a hole in the living
room ceiling
where he accidentally stepped off the
joist and through the ceiling
this sort of seems a little bit like you
know like a a national lampoon's
vacation going on here
so i hope that you are safe and that you
eventually patch that hole which is
another home improvement project
see how one home improvement project
leads to another
so with all his great home improvements
please welcome alex to the stage
thanks jared cool thanks so much uh
everybody for for being here um
my name is alex i'm a solutions engineer
at our studio
i just want to start off with a huge
thanks to jared and the lander analytics
team
um i love this conference i love the
lander team
so it's just a delight to get to be here
and thanks to all of you all who are
tuning in
um my twitter handle is down there at
the bottom uh so feel free to tweet at
me if you like what you see or if you
don't
that's cool too uh love love hearing
that um and i will tweet out a link to
these slides after
uh after the talk so um the the
titleist talk is is powerful or going
along with with my theme song
um easier better faster stronger um
i figure after my fun fact i need to
provide some like evidence so uh
this is what my living room looked like
on
saturday there where i stepped right
through but this is what it looks like
now i've started patching it like jared
said i just made more home improvement
work for myself i have two more coats to
do
we'll get there that's that's going to
be this weekend uh anyway
i just wanted to like introduce myself a
little bit because i think sort of the
credibility of what i'm going to talk
about really depends on whether like
you think i'm credible so i just want to
share a little bit about who i am so
um as i said i work at our studio now as
a solutions engineer
but this is sort of by far the least dc
job
i've i've ever had um my background is
in is in the public sector i was in the
dc
think tank world for a long time working
on economic policy research
after that i sort of went into politics
and did data science in the political
realm working on voter outreach
experiments
and i was a data scientist and a data
science team lead for a federal
consulting firm so
i do have a lot of experience working in
sort of the public sector and with the
government
um and and during that time several of
those teams i went through transitions
so i went through a state-of-the-art
transition uh
for any of you whose background is in
economics i'm sure you have lots of
fun stories about stata like i do um
also did some excel and tableau to our
kind of kind of transitions
and and now at our studio um i work with
customers that are going through that
transition and so
um that's a little bit of what i'm going
to talk about today is is sort of um
how to use our packages in in that
transition
um so uh let's get started
so over the past couple days we've heard
a lot about like getting our into
federal agencies we've heard about sort
of like
some of the certification difficulties
how like getting the software prepped is
hard
the the security requirements are high
those sorts of things
um i'm going to totally ignore all of
that for the purposes of this talk i'm
going to assume that sort of like
somebody else paved that road for you uh
like wendy and william gave those great
talks yesterday
about sort of how that process works um
but but even once that is
done there's you're not you're not
finished yet right like
even once you have r that's allowable in
your
organization and that's true whether
you're in like a federal organization a
consulting organization or like
something totally unrelated uh you
actually need to get people to use are
you to get
buy-in and because you're here
i'm going to assume that this applies to
you like you probably want to do more r
you probably want your team to do more r
and so um i'm going to talk a little bit
today about like some strategies to get
there and of course
i'm going to talk about it using my
personal
favorite tool uh which is of course the
r package and
and not just like any r package we're
going to talk about the power of
of building your own our package so
going to start off talking a little bit
about why why you would build an r
package
um whenever i talk about the house or
the strategy
and also the mechanics of of building uh
your your r package
um for those of you who built lots of
our packages before the mechanics piece
is gonna be pretty basic but
i think it's worth going through because
the tooling has gotten so good
it's really easy to make in our package
and there's just no excuse for not doing
it
um so let's let's start off with why
why would you for your team want to
write
an r package um and the answer of course
is that it will make your work easier uh
it gives
everyone access to the same set of tools
um and provides a pathway
to get everyone sort of onboarded to
those tools to get everyone
using those tools um it's better uh it
gives access gives
everyone access to like elite level
tools right like everybody gets to take
advantage
of the knowledge of like the most
knowledgeable person
on the team uh it makes your work faster
because your iteration will be shorter
right if you if you do something this
time with a project
uh you turn that into code next time
that gets faster
this virtuous cycle that's the whole
benefit of using code to do
to do data science and of course
stronger right because
code in a package can be validated it
can be tested
in ways that are hard to do in just sort
of like a vanilla analysis it can make
your analysis more bulletproof
you may even have requirements that your
um
your your analyses be validated in
certain ways and a package can really
sort of
aid uh with with how that all works um
so of course we're gonna we're gonna
talk a little about like
how to make um our packages and use them
to make your work easier better faster
and stronger so you know you're here
at this conference so i'm going to
assume you're like the r
expert on your team or at least like the
r enthusiast they are evangelist
um and so like very often this story
goes and i've i've heard some great
talks here at dcr talking about how to
do in our package and like like
jared said i've been coming to this
conference for for a bunch of years i
love this conference
uh and and i've i i think the first one
of these conferences i came to
i went home and i was like let's write
an r package team and so like
the idea was like i'm gonna write this r
package it's gonna be amazing
then like team everybody is going to use
it like that's
that's great the the problem is that
like it totally didn't work
because like this this is what i call
like the expert package development
pattern
and this can work there are there are
cases where this works
but there are a couple of problems here
right um
first of all like adoption is really
hard so like maybe
these people on your team are really
familiar with r but like maybe they
don't like the way you wrote the package
maybe like you didn't write things that
were helpful
for them or the api isn't good uh maybe
like this person
is like really a tableau person and like
they don't really know are and don't
particularly care that you've like
written in our package that
doesn't really help them maybe this
person is an excel person they're like
you know doing whatever they're doing
doing all their stuff in excel maybe
this person
is like a new grad and like they don't
know what they're doing they're just
like figuring out
you know what is this whole thing and so
and so
you know adoption here can be really
hard because people are comfortable with
different tools
the the other big problem here is that
like
it assumes that the only relevant
expertise is
our language expertise um you know but
the other kinds of there are many other
kinds of
expertise you might want to sort of
encode in your package like data
visualization or like visual design
right like maybe you want to have custom
gg plot functions in there
maybe you want to have custom markdown
templates or css for your shiny apps
right like that
that probably should go in your package
maybe you have like custom machine
learning or stats things that want to go
in there like
for example there was a at a previous
job of mine
we had to derive our standard errors for
estimates in certain ways and like the
person who
understood the standard errors best um
and like understood the derivation of
those standard errors was not the best
our programmer
on the team um or or like this this is
one that comes up all the time i think
especially in like the federal context
but really like
every place ever which is that like the
data model right like the data access
is sort of complicated and like there's
like that one person on the team who
like
knows how to actually access the data
and the rest of you want to take
advantage of that but like
you don't all know like this came up in
a previous job of mine
um one of the guys on the team he he was
really
we were we were doing hospital data and
so like we had all these different data
sets like the admissions were separate
from the diagnoses and like you have to
match them up to do anything meaningful
but like
there was one person on the team who
like understood how they matched up
and so we really wanted to encode that
into a package but like
that he wasn't in our programmer and so
like that was really hard
so i want to suggest two other models of
package development
that can be way more effective at
actually getting your team
to use those our packages and so the
first one is you know particularly if
you're a team where you have people
using all kinds of different tools
is like you going home all jazzed up
from the dcr conference
uh you know your job is to start the
package maybe maybe you write the
package skeleton
but but then the idea is that you get
everyone else to contribute code
to the package right everybody adds
their own code
to the package and the the idea here
right the the
the goal is both that along the way
maybe you work with some folks they
learn some more are they get more
comfortable with the r package
but the other part which is even more
important is that they get excited right
this package then is
theirs they've helped design the package
they've helped write the package
this is just an incredible way to get
buy-in from your team on being like yes
we are going to use r because it is
awesome like we had experience writing
this package
uh and now we're going to to use it it's
just it's a great way to get
everyone involved and get everyone
bought in on using your our package
um i call this the the everyone package
pattern because
everybody is contributing to the package
um the the other pattern i want to talk
about um
is is a pattern that is maybe for teams
where sort of people are more
comfortable with r
but you're trying to figure out how to
make your your um
your project's more verifiable more
reproducible
um and and that is the sort of package
per project uh so like for every project
you're working on like
folks work on a package that corresponds
to that project this is the per project
package and this is really
a great strategy when like your primary
goal
is to increase the sort of testability
and verifiability
of your analyses um one thing i do want
to remark
is a lot uh sometimes this gets
interpreted as
make your project into a package
um i am personally not a huge fan of
that pattern
uh maybe you are maybe this is where i'm
gonna get yelled at on twitter but i'm
okay with it
um i don't love the project as package
there is an r
project and there is a package and they
are distinct entities uh and i
i really like to use them for their
intended purpose so uh i recommend that
that folks sort of adopt this kind of
strategy where they have you know an r
project uh
sorry just a project directory that not
like that's where the git repo is
uh then you have separate like package
and project
subdirectories they're parallel but
they're not
the same um and then like
your functions go in the functions
inside the r package
uh your tests go in the tests and then
you have
separate like actual um code that you
know builds your report
does your app sort of whatever whatever
you need it to do
um again my recommendation is to keep
those things separate
uh because i i find that this is a
cleaner division of labor it helps with
separation of concerns better in terms
of writing good
clean code helps with testability if you
happen to be using
um our studio package manager or rstudio
connect it just works much more cleanly
in terms of the deployment pipeline
um and so you know i i really recommend
this um if you want to read more about
this actually
uh miles mcbain wrote a great blog post
on this topic i don't have the link
handy i probably should have gotten that
but
uh he wrote a really good blog post he
he also uh he's like
you know uh an art community kind of guy
and and um
he he also thinks like the project
package
is great but um not the project as
package so anyway that's that's my
soapbox uh and i'm i'm
gonna get off it now and just talk about
some less controversial things um so now
i wanna do a quick demo
of um of how this works like in reality
how you can create an r package
in really just a few minutes so like
i've got
about eight minutes left in my talk and
i think i can get this our package
written
easily uh in in the time we we have left
so um i'm gonna pull up our studio
server here
um and so here's a function that i wrote
uh first let me just load it and i'll
just show you what it does
so this this function uh gives me
a random lyric from the song harder
better faster stronger
by um uh daft punk um
i can also ask for a specific line from
the song
so like that should give me back the
same line uh by the way this
this uh function makes use of the genius
package which is a crayon package
written by my colleague josiah at our
studio it's very fun if you want to get
song lyrics
um so let's just talk through like what
the code here is
is doing oops wrong one ah where'd my
source pane go
oh there it is
all right let's talk through what the
source code is doing here
uh so we've got uh
my function definition here uh i'm
grabbing all of the lyrics for this song
using the the genius package um then
if somebody if this line was specified
i'm taking that or i'm gonna sample a
random line
and then this is just sort of pulling
and returning that line
um so again i can i can show you that
sort of
i'm too zoomed in it's hard to see
everything uh
i can show you know that's that's how
that works that's that's pretty
pretty straightforward so now let's turn
this into a package
so uh with the use this package creating
a package
is so trivially easy i'm gonna do use
this
if i spell it correctly uh create
package i'm going to specify a name daft
package
great package name alex um
i'm gonna open my session
it's gonna take just a second to load up
and what you'll see is that what um
what use this does is it creates the
whole package skeleton for me this is
this makes it super easy right like for
any of you who know about package
creations it's created a description for
me
i can fill in like what this actually
does um
and and it's giving me my name space as
well it's actually empty uh unlike if
you do
new package up here it doesn't have that
hello world function which i actually
prefer so anyway i recommend you use
this
over up here that's if you already
create packages
um and so now now what i'm going to do
is to
now add my function to my package i'm
going to just copy and paste in my
function definition i'm going to save it
daft
function um
and so now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to write some documentation for
this function
i can go up here to code insert oxygen
skeleton
or i can just hit what is that command
alt shift
r to insert it um
and i'm going to
[Music]
a good song i'm going to write my
documentation
which line
defaults to n a
random
returns a character
and i'm gonna put an example here
right like that so here are a couple of
awesome things about this thing one is
that if it's
if i have an example here in the
examples i can just run it
uh if i had loaded up my function
uh the other great thing is that now
when i do devtools
document so this is my favorite moment
uh the like moment where like i feel
like i've written a real thing
where i go daft lyric
and like there is real function document
it's taking moments right
my moment you're ruining my moment um
here we go that like this is real
function documentation that got
auto-generated
from my comments over here and this is
like whenever i'm writing a new package
this is just like my
favorite moment where it's like wow i
did a real thing that's so cool
um anyway so now that i've now that i've
rendered it i'm going to load up my
my function and i'm going to run my
function
oh except it doesn't work uh because i
didn't have the pipe here
right like this is actually not from my
package same thing with dplyer
and genius like those are outside
packages that just get referenced
and so i need to make sure i include
those so i'm going to do use this
use pipe and it's that easy to add the
magritter pipe
to um to your uh uh um
package uh and similarly if i want to
use uh use this
use package if i want to add d plier and
genius
i don't have to remember how to add them
i just like use the use this
package and in case any of you are
curious where that goes it gets added
here to the description so that
it now knows that it imports those and
if somebody were to load up my package
for the first time they would be auto
installed
uh those those uh um packages would be
auto installed for them
all right so now if i do uh
document again
load it up
huzzah it works do it faster work is
over
right like these are uh uh classic
lyrics here real
real poetry okay so
uh we have about two minutes and 30
seconds left we're gonna add some tests
in that last two minutes and 30 seconds
and so this is
again almost trivially easy to make this
verifiable
uh we're gonna do use test that test
that is an r package
that allows you to add tests really
easily to um
to an um it is a package that makes it
really easy to add test to a package
a little bit of mouthful now i'm going
to run use tests
daft test i'm going to open up my test
file
and let me make this a little bigger
i'm going to test lyric
getting um then what i'm going to do
is i'm going to use these expect
functions these expect functions are
going to make it really easy to get
the expectations i wrote out mine ahead
of time here just to make this go a
little faster so what i'm doing here is
i'm getting the lyrics sort of ahead of
time and then i'm checking
with this expect true that my lyric that
it returns is
in this this lyric which by the way is
just a data frame that looks like this
in case you're curious right i'm
checking that it's in this lyric vector
and so now with devtools test
it's going to load my package run my
tests i
am a coding rock star wow that's so
exciting it even gives you encouraging
messages it's one of my favorite
features of uh
of uh test that here so anyway so that's
it we created our package we added tests
all of a sudden that work that i did to
write this function has become so much
more verifiable
it can be reused across different
analyses like that was
almost trivial to do um and so
you know i cannot emphasize strongly
enough how much
this can be a tool for you and a tool
for you to onboard your team
to the awesomeness of using r uh anyway
that's what i've got to share thank you
so much for tuning in um
if you are interested in more about
writing our packages uh there is an r
packages
book written by hadley wickham and i
believe jenny bryan
um it is free for use online it is
fantastic
uh really just a great a great read uh
if you're curious about our packages
uh we talked about using the use this
and test that packages
if you're curious about then like once
you've created the package how do you
manage it i'm going to be doing a public
webinar on this uh
uh with our studio so stay tuned on the
uh webinars
webinars at rstudio.com if you want to
sign up you can get alerted to our
upcoming webinars to learn more about
how you sort of manage your package
environment
but the very short version is that uh
you can use the rn
open source package to manage the set of
packages you have installed in your
environment
and our studio package manager is a
product that our studio sells that
allows you to manage
the packages in the repository
environment including
if you are offline or air gapped uh
that's it
thanks so much for tuning in and feel
free to tweet at me
um thanks jared and lander analytics for
having
me thank you for presenting here and if
you want to learn more
from alex he's doing a meet the speaker
during lunch
so i believe lunch starts at
roughly 12 25 go
to the our studio booth during lunch and
meet alex and talk to them about
writing packages or about how you patch
holes in the ceilings of your house
because both are useful skills depending
what you're doing
um you know he did mention um
building packages using remv and our
studio package manager
and i've been using remv a lot it's a
nice uh way to
keep individual packages for different
projects he also mentioned
miles mcbain has his nice blog post
about
project management and so we've had both
miles mcbain
um we have miles mcbain's talk of the
mute up a few months ago
and he gave a whole talk about using
drake which is a great way to manage
projects if you're onto the package
based project you can do the drink based
project
so if you go to nyhackr.org you can find
miles's talk there
but this week literally two nights ago
three nights ago
on tuesday however many nights ago there
was three nights ago we had the author
of the drake package will landau
come give a talk about the successor to
drake which is targets
so you want to learn more about miles
and you want to learn more about
will check out nyhackguard.org miles's
talk is already up there
will's is not posted online i don't
think yet just because we went straight
from the meetup into the conference
it'll definitely be posted by next week
but those are great resources for you i
i
i've learned a lot from miles's blog
post um and from
will's talk and everything oh will's
talk is up i just heard amada just told
me
um will's talk is up so you go to my
hackguard.org you can see talks from
both
will and miles mcbain talking about uh
project workflows and everything that's
really fast work thank you omada and
michael for getting that stuff up there
so quickly